okay so my name is Hank and yep I'm here
to suggest to you that if first you
don't succeed it beating HQ trivia try
cheating and if you don't like the word
cheating we can call it tool assisted
game playing if that makes you feel
better series a little bit about me I
mean I list developer at lift right now
I have a cute dog named soda pop and I
like to win and so just to get this out
of the way I have a little Twitter fight
going on I'm trying to get the most
pictures of my dog into my presentation
to be Joel and so here's a slide that
has a lot of pictures of my dog so we're
done with that let's talk about HQ
trivia so HQ tribute is a live trivia
game oh here let me restart this it's a
freezing should be animated I have a lot
of animated gifs in my presentation so
that's really important okay yep so HQ
trivia is a live trivia game that you
can play on your phone you have to
answer 12 multiple-choice questions you
have 10 seconds to answer each question
and you can win cash prizes if you
answer all of them right the prizes are
sometimes really big and sometimes
they're like 50 cents it just kind of
depends on like how many people win and
what the prize is so what's a problem
here as the game progresses it gets
really really hard the questions get
really really hard and so if you're
really just guessing randomly the odds
are really really low that you're
actually going to win and if you're han
Solo you might say okay well I don't
care I'm just gonna guess randomly but
for people like me probably need a
little bit more help and so how can we
beat HQ trivia so I had a little thought
process you know but I google it really
fast or I can write a neural network but
at the end I want to write an app
that'll google it really fast and so
like let's divide and conquer this
problem so if you want to build an app
that can play HQ trivia for number one I
have to get the actual question and
multiple answers from my iPhone app and
then put into another app and then after
that I have to actually make a search
query that can help me decide like which
answer I want to pick within 10 seconds
which is kind of a lot of time pressure
kind of like this talk okay so one thing
about me is I'm an iOS developer and so
every problem that I look at the
solution looks like an iPhone app
that's not necessarily the best way to
solve problems it's kind of like if you
have a hammer everything looks like a
nail
and so originally I wrote an iPhone app
to solve this and then eventually I
wrote a Mac app and so now that we know
what the problem is we know what we want
to use to solve it let's just get down
to the nitty-gritty right let's get the
show on the road so step one so this is
really good timing because Apple
actually released a vision framework
last year double WC and so what this
does and one of the things it does is it
can actually detect text rectangles and
so you can see in the screenshot it's
actually doing a pretty good job of
finding where the text is so you might
be thinking to yourself does this
actually do OCR and one thing that
surprises people when I talk to them
about vision is that actually doesn't do
the optical character recognition for
you so you have to do that on your own
and so oops yeah and so it's up to use
OCR and so originally I was going to
write you know or train this model to do
character recognition based on like
inputs from the app screenshots and
everything but I just didn't really have
time and I kind of want us to start
winning and so I ended up using an open
source project called tesseract it works
really really well and so that's step
two so step three is to Google it I was
looking at the Google custom search
engine API and it kind of looked like it
wanted you to only choose one domain or
a few multiple domains but I really
wanted was the entire Internet right and
so what I did was I just made a get
request to Google the search like URL
and then eventually I got blocked and it
said hey you're a robot and they're
partly right I guess I was a robot and
so I moved on to the the Bing Web API
and so I used that for a little bit but
they actually want to charge you money
and I don't want to pay money just to
win HT trivia especially if it's like 50
cents and so the solution I finally
ended up with is to use Safari inside of
my app and so again yeah it's like an
iOS and Mac you know you can have a
webview and so basically I load Google
up I use JavaScript to put the query and
then I hit the submit button and then
Google is like okay you're cool you're
your goal person so another advantage to
this too is that you can actually see
the context of the search results page
while you're trying to play HQ trivia
okay so we have that out of the way we
actually still need to figure out like
what a good search
where he is right because this is more
of a heuristic approach there's not like
an algorithm that's going to get you the
right answer all the time so like how
can we get close to helping us decide
what to put in there so one option I had
was you probably can't read that but
it's answer or asking three different
questions with the answer combination
and so and then then looking to see how
many search results there are and I
thought this would be a good idea but it
basically tells you like which is most
popular not necessarily what's correct
and so then I tried it again with all
the answers I'm just a pin it at the end
and then we can see here the question is
like what is playing music in public
places called and busking is the right
answer and here it shows up five times
and the other two times that actually
showed up we're in reference to the HT
trivia question itself and so that's
pretty good making a small optimisation
for that you can also wrap those answers
in or and so then what this does is it
kind of prevents you from getting search
results from pages that have all of
those queries or all those answers that
just kind of isolates you to the right
answer so that's a little bit better so
this is a screenshot of what the
original iOS app looked like it was kind
of clunky because I had to have two
phones so I had one phone running HQ
trivia and I had another phone that I
was pointing at it to do CR and so this
was kinda stupid I quickly learned that
there was a better way and so I ended up
running a Mac app and so this is the Mac
up I have currently or almost currently
so what it does is you airplay your
screen to your Mac and then your Mac
takes a screenshot of that and then the
OCR is actually a lot better because
it's a nice clean screenshot and the the
search results show up so you kind of
scan it and get a better idea of what
the right answer might be so while it's
doing research for this talk I actually
found some people who did a little bit
more research and had a different way to
solve the first problem and so there's
these blogpost I can't read them to you
right now because I'm in the middle of a
talk but I'll probably like post you
somewhere so you can read those too
because I want to give those people
credit but basically what they found was
that if you use to Lake Charles to look
at the network traffic between h2 trivia
and their back end you can actually find
a WebSocket they can connect to and then
you can get all of the the chats and all
the question/answer combo so you don't
have to do OCR at all
so I basically wasted a lot of my own
time
but that's because I wanted to write nap
right and so I looked at that and I was
like okay actually I can I can build on
top of this right and so I built a new
feature it's called a ski audience so
it's like Who Wants to Be a Millionaire
I can scan all these chat questions and
often people in HQ try to put in the
answer that they think is right so like
the chat is scrolling so fast it usually
can't see it but it programmatically you
know I can just look at those answers
and then have a tally of them and so the
sample question I want to use is what
word is a wreath or frankly and spell
out in our iconic 1967 hit so let's
let's see how well this works right so
we're looking accounting counting and
yes nailed it all right so yeah you guys
remember the Robocop that was a classic
song so yeah in the end it didn't really
work that well and I wasted more of my
own time and this kind of like validates
my idea and I think a lot of people's
idea that you just never read the
comments just never look at them swipe
them away so yeah in the end like how
well as my solver actually do I guess
about 70 to 80 percent of the questions
right and that's still not good enough
to win and then there's also this weird
like meta game you have to play where
you not only do you have to try and
figure out what what answer is right you
have to figure out whether or not the
robot is right or not so it's like two
games in one and it kind of takes the
fun out of it a little bit too but so
does losing so how can the HQ actually
like defeat cheaters it actually does
pretty well and so there are certain
questions that Google just can't really
answer it very quickly it skewed a
little bit better job with like
certificate painting so you can actually
look at the network traffic and they
prevent QuickTime sessions but for some
reason they don't prevent airplay so
that's how I got around that problem so
here's some examples of HQ questions
that are hard to answer for Google so
one of them is if you ask things about
like the first or the last
you know extremes then it's really hard
for Google to come up with that like the
way I would do it in person is just to
look at like a list of country names and
then search each one but you can't do
that in ten seconds another one is to
add like it red herring quiz answers and
these are kind of like savage questions
right so Jackie Robinson is known for
playing for the Brooklyn Dodgers
but this question is actually asking
about this minor league baseball and so
the right answer is Montreal which most
people got wrong
so yeah that's all about all I have in
closing if you want to follow me I'm on
Twitter it can't afford my dog he's on
Instagram and if you haven't played HD
trivia you can sign up with my referral
code and I can get extra lives and I
want to actually leave with one one more
thought and maybe it's that the real HQ
trigger prizes there were technologies
we learned okay thank you
[Applause]